Thank You Robin and thank you also to
Joan why and the nickel team and Deena
Michelle and the amazing extraordinarily
hard-working Academy staff who made this
night possible they're the ones that did
the heavy lifting so let's give them a
big hand you've heard what they say
about making it in this business it's
all about who you know it's about
networking and lunches and what gym you
go to where you might run into just the
right person with just the right project
is just right for you it's knowing a
friend of a friend of a friend of a
friend of an agent who knows a guy with
an IP that's gonna be the next big thing
it's having that roommate in film school
that owes you or the parent and the VIS
who makes you feel terrible about
yourself until you became more famous
than they are what I love about the
Nicholls felt nickel fellowship is that
it throws all this out the damn window
it's not about who you know it's about
what you do often the nickel fellow is
not someone who knows anyone they are
outsiders their family therapists
stay-at-home moms educators children of
immigrants and Native American tribe
members they come from all over the
country
Texas Los Angeles Missouri Minnesota
they come from different schools
different backgrounds different lives
they are from everywhere and they are
everybody the only thing they have in
common is the fierce desire to write no
matter how how hard it was for them they
wrote no matter how much life or family
or finances or jobs told them they
couldn't or even well-meaning friends
told them they should try something else
they wrote it was a compulsion a dream
an unstoppable Drive that made them keep
going despite the very slim to none
chance that their writing would ever be
seen by anyone all these people these
wonderful different people are writers
and that is why we are here tonight so
tonight we're here to celebrate their
obsession we're here to introduce them
to all of you to revel in their
different voices as writers to hear
their stories of tough women in trouble
doomsday preppers drug abuse and math I
hope you enjoy this evening as we bark
embark on a new year of fellowship as we
welcome these writers as those people
you may want to know Congrats again to
the 2018 nickel fellows
now a friendly reminder that there is no
photography or video during this event I
know it's sad
now this evening would definitely not be
possible without these four amazing and
talented people joining us tonight let
me introduce the actors will be
performing scenes flew Nicole winning
scripts jamie chung currently stars in
the television series the gifted and
reprises her role voicing gogo Tomago
and big hero 6 the series she also stars
in the feature film 1985 which premiered
this spring at South by Southwest her
other feature credits include band-aid
big hero 6 - Hangover Part 3 and The
Hangover Part two
jamie chung blair Underwood has been
seen most recently as a series regular
on the television series Quantico and is
currently in production on Ava Duvernay
ease miniseries Central Park 5 his
feature film credits include full
frontal rules of engagement just cause
and the upcoming juanita blair Underwood
Golden Globe nominated actress Lily
Collins will be next be seen being seen
as Fantine in the television miniseries
adaptation of lemaise rock she recently
completed production on extremely wicked
shockingly Yvonne vile and Tolkien
Collins recently started such features
as oak jaw to the bone and rules don't
apply her other film credits include
love Rosie the English teacher stuck in
love Mirror Mirror and The Blind Side
Lily Collins kenji young most recently
starred in crazy rich Asians and is
widely known for his role as mr. Chow in
the hangover movies his other feature
credits include knocked up
role models and ride-along - he was a
regular on the television comedy series
community and created and starred in
doctor Ken he will next be seen in the
celebrity singing competition the masked
singer and well as well on his own
stand-up comedy special Ken's young
[Applause]